Finally, in person, Damona Hoffman!
(audience applauds)
Damona, I've never done this segment without you.
We've done it several times, but the very first time we met,
you mentioned the digital hanky, which is what we can draw.
You shifted my perspective
with that beautiful pairing of words.
Digital hanky.
Thank you.
Okay, well, according to a report from Tinder,
Gen Z has changed the future of dating
with their new interest in digital dates.
And Damona, do you agree
that digital dates are here to stay?
Definitely.
And I also agree that they're not just for Gen Z.
Everyone is adopting digital dating
because obviously you kinda had to .
I have always recommended it as a screening step.
So that's what I think might change.
People are now using it as a replacement for the date,
but if you can use it as a screening step,
keep it short and sweet,
and then, you know, get prepared for it
like you would for a regular date.
You know, sometimes people are like,
I'll just do a quick little FaceTime date
and then they don't think about
that's their first impression.
That's the first time someone's going to see them.
So if you think of your lighting, you think of like,
not having your dirty underwear in the back
and really set the stage for a great meet-cute.
It can still work in the digital space.
Well, let's chat with two women of different ages
looking to better their online dating game.
Please welcome Aime and Alison!
(audience applauds)
Okay, so Aime, tell me what's going on in your dating life?
Well, I'm exhausted.
I've got the digital burnout.
I dated really, really heavily
in my twenties and my thirties,
and I've been on the apps all of that time.
And the dating pool is just getting really shallow.
Actually, so shallow I'm in repeats.
(audience laughs)
What does that mean? (laughs)
Is this a Samantha Jones moment where you're like,
I've been with you before.
(Damona laughs)
Yes.
In 2016, I went out with this guy
and it didn't, you know, didn't go well.
We didn't really hit it off.
And then in 2019, I went out with the same guy
and we didn't realize that we'd been out with each other
until we were halfway through the date.
When you did realize it, can I ask
what you guys said or did?
I think we just said, oh.
And then we just continued.
We just continued on our date.
And we ended up having a good time the second time around.
Maybe keeping an open mind is a good thing.
But don't ask me, ask Damona.
Do you have a question for Damona?
Yeah, Damona, how do I keep dating fun?
Because right now, it's kind of a drag.
I'm just, I'm exhausted.
How does this stay fun?
I hear that burnout, and what I see here is
by having so many options, it actually brings up anxiety.
It takes the fun out of it, right?
And it makes you not wanna do it anymore.
So I'm gonna give you some advice
that may be a little counter intuitive.
[ Okay.
I'm gonna have you pull back.
How many hours a day would you say you spend on your dating?
Probably two or three.
Well, if you are on the apps for that much time,
nothing's gonna look good to you anymore.
Right.
So I want you to limit the time
that you're spending on apps.
I'm gonna give you 15 minutes a day.
That's it.
Okay.
Because that would force you to make a choice
and not just keep swiping
and looking for the next best thing.
And the other thing I want you to try
is something I call cycling.
So this is when you start on one dating app,
take all of the other apps off your phone
and spend four to six weeks on that one app.
And then after four to six weeks, you can go to another app
and then you get boosted in the algorithm
because you're new.
Everyone you see there is new and shiny.
You can get really excited again,
and that cycling gives you a fresh perspective
and new options that you might not have seen before.
I like that.
That's a really interesting thing
that I've never tried before.
I aim to please!
I learn so much with you, Damona,
it like, crushes my soul in the best way ever.
(upbeat bright music)